hello i'm martha mutchler i'm a
vegetable breeder
with an emphasis on the discovery of new
traits and their transfer into
domesticated vegetables
the central theme of my work has been to
reduce the loss of crop or crop quality
that is caused by biotic stresses such
as diseases
insects or insect transmitted virus
while reducing
the use of fungicides pesticides and
other sprays for biotic stress control
for example in the northeast u.s and
similar regions we have cooler moisture
production conditions so the major
diseases are fungal oomyc diseases such
as late blight early blight and septoria
leaf spot
in order to substantially reduce the use
of fungicides we must control all three
of these diseases not just one therefore
what we did was to
obtain resistances to each of the three
diseases either by discovering them
ourselves
or by obtaining them from other
researchers and transfer them all into
the same lines such as the plants here
as a result of having resistances to all
three of these diseases
the plants of the lines or hybrids made
with them
require only
one or two sprays of fungicide per
season instead of the typical 10 to 12 a
substantial reduction in the use of
fungicide while gaining greater control
of the disease
to control multiple insects and the
virus they transmit we've transferred a
trait from a wild tomato to domestic
tomato
that allows the production of high
levels of acid sugars which are a
trichome exidate produced all over the
plant the aeso sugar droplets can
reflect light
when the drops are large enough you can
see the droplets on the leaf as a slight
shimmer as in this picture
when the insects land on the plant they
encounter this exudate which is a severe
irritant repelling the insects which
immediately leave most often without
having fed
if the insect doesn't feed it doesn't
transmit the virus
this form of resistance works against
um
western flower thrip which transmits a
horrible disease called tomato spotted
wilt virus
and it works against the bemesia
whitefly or silverleaf whitefly that
transmits
begomoviruses such as tomato yellow leaf
curl virus
these two vectors and viruses are two of
the most critical ones throughout the
world in tropical and subtropical
regions
plants that produce sufficient levels of
the acid sugars
suppress virus under field conditions
under heavy infestation in trial fields
in florida
and in california
and work very well under severe
conditions in greenhouse and laboratory
conditions
the plants you see here are all members
of our
research tomato lines for the acyl sugar
project
the different lines have different acyl
sugar qtls or combinations of qtls as
they produce different levels or types
of acid sugars
using these related lines
researchers can test to see which levels
or types of basil sugars give the best
control of insects and insect
transmitted virus
with this
information we can choose which levels
and types of basil sugar give optimal
control of the greatest number of
insects and virus
transmission
and therefore give us our breeding goal
these lines would not be useful to a
seed company
because
the integrations carrying the eso sugar
lines are a bit too large
and some of them carry additional genes
that negatively impact either plant type
fruit set
or fruit quality
so to create lines that would be good
for seed companies to use
we have been systematically reducing the
sizes of the integrations using
recombination
determining which reductions in
integration size
provides us the loss of the qtl
regulating the negative trait
while retaining the acyl sugar traits
we then pyramid together the
integrations necessary for the
appropriate level of acid sugars
and the elimination of each of the
negative traits in about one year we
will have the final breeding lines that
will be
far more normal for plant type and fruit
type and fruit set
but have the acyl sugar mediated
resistance we desired
these lines will be released to seed
companies for transfer of this trait
into commercial lines and hybrids
this is our goal
use of the eso sugar mediated insect
resistance
will provide control of insects and
control a pest using a natural compound
which is not toxic
and provide
control of these insects and virus
without the use of pesticides
pesticides are an issue in production
because they are expensive
they can be hazardous to growers
farm workers and consumers and the
environment
indeed some pesticides can be
neurotoxins
so we have devoted so many years and so
much effort to the
transfer of this trait
in order to eliminate pesticide usage
this has been a production of cornell
university on the web at cornell.edu